if you want to know who's doing the
heavy lifting on the protocol you should
speak to a haulage firm and it's staff
grappling with a surge in red tape the
protocol hurts our customers
and it hurts our customers moving goods
between britain and northern ireland for
example a shipment of meals for nursing
homes sent across from great britain one
consignment can have 80 90 pages of
documentation just to move it across the
rac
the bureaucracy that's involved in it
and the errors that can happen across
those 90 pages have resulted in that
product been held in belfast and
returned to great britain
because the paper works wrong nothing
wrong with the product
one error in the paperwork for peter new
legislation from london could offer some
hope it's essential that something is
done to ease the complex movements that
happen between great britain and
northern ireland and the current
position does not address those problems
it's expected the government's bill will
contain provisions to effectively
abolish the controversial irish sea
customs checks the eu will see that as a
breach of law not so according to the
northern ireland secretary people will
see that what we are proposing resolves
the key issues within the protocol that
don't work so what is the legal basis on
which you're publishing this advice well
we have to actually outline what we're
doing in a context that is about
protecting the integrity of the belfast
good friday group and we as a government
will be outlining our legal position and
being particularly about why this is
absolutely within the law that earned
him this riposte from sinn fein's leader
brandon lewis is talking through his hat
and not for the first time the british
government has refused to engage uh has
not been constructive has sought a
destructive path and is now proposing to
introduce legislation that will
undoubtedly breach international law of
course there are also sectors here that
see the protocol as offering them
shelter from the brexit economic
downpour offering companies unfettered
access both to the uk market and the
european market of
million consumers an advantage enjoyed
nowhere else in the united kingdom to
them new legislation risks upsetting
that arrangement peter says he would
welcome the scrapping of customs checks
if that's what liz trust reveals in
westminster but he's worried about what
economic countermeasures the eu will
impose and that seems almost certain one
irish government source saying that
brussels is in no mood to mess around
stephen murphy sky news in belfast